i could say like you're like really good
at walking what almonds me you have like
weird teas weird teasers
used to use your toilet because mine
didn't work where you were
hey i'm uh robert
i'm zoe kravitz and we're from the movie
the batman
and we're gonna do this buzzfeed co-star
test
let's do it
here are the rules oh sweating check off
each of the details you're absolutely
sure
you know about your co-star go you're
doing the first all right here we go
their full birthday what's your birthday
[Laughter]
okay rob's birthday
is in it's in may
half a point
when's my birthday i think you're a
capricorn no
sagittarius yes i don't know when
sagittarius
it's like at the end of the year you
seem like a kind of christmas christmas
day by jesus christmas child i would say
i said january like i know towards the
end like 28th of december or something
like that maybe beginning january
it's the opposite of what you're saying
you said beginning end of january
beginning of december yes
one point for me okay no okay so i think
we know the same amount i know that your
birthday's in may you know that my
birthday is sometime in december yeah
and it was sort of towards the end
neither one okay i know what your middle
name is isabella is it yeah i don't know
what your middle name is no one does the
dressing room must have
i actually know what because i actually
went in your dressing room what
it was without you realizing you used to
use your toilet because mine didn't work
where no you didn't that's not true
you have little candles
yeah
i have candles how else did i know
no i water my accident once
coca-cola no no i don't really have any
must-haves i'm never even in the
dressing room ever no i don't know him
okay you get that one too i do have
noodles their go-to activity in between
filming scenes i don't know you look
good do you have like tea and stuff you
have like weird teas weird teas
or coffee coffee
like that's coffee yeah yeah i do yeah
yeah one point okay coffee order i think
he had the same one as me then you have
like a
their first role harry potter that
wasn't actually my first role but one of
that's like come on that's pretty good
though i get this one i've got no idea
i'm sorry oh my first role was
um in a film called no reservations
starring catherine zeta jones
and aaron eckhart i love that movie no
you don't yeah dude really yeah i had no
idea that's pretty good i love the movie
yeah i play the goth babysitter i have
like two lines first time you met we met
when we auditioned together mm-hmm for
remember or remember me did not get that
part but i think we met at a party
before that i think you're thinking
which was way later that was when we
were really i was like 21 years old when
i did that we both know that yeah the
last project before working on the you
were doing tennis
were you doing your show what show oh
god this is terrible i know what it's
called
you don't know i do know what it's
called
[Music]
it's like
it's like i'm getting confused with
crazy rich asians and i'm thinking it's
like rich lady you don't know
rich
you don't know it's not even that one
okay
oh oh hi fidel oh [ __ ]
was that last project you're working
before yeah it's so good no one wants to
hire me their favorite scene you filmed
together you told me the other day the
fight scene
i did love yes well you agreed with me
when i said i also liked the scene in my
apartment yes yes great great their
favorite snack at crafts almonds me you
were asking problems yesterday that's
sydney thing i didn't see you eat
anything though
it's white fish
can i have one more cram their favorite
batman film aside from that boobs one of
the michael
keaton
yes okay fat member sounds right okay
and yours says
the first one i reckon no i would say
the dark knight i do love the dark
knight because of heath i win
i am the winner their hometown are you
born in london yes
new york
no ah literally told me that the other
day i live in new york until i was born
in new york paris no
l.a yeah
dennis beach bra their hidden talent
you're a really good singer he can sing
yeah how is this like the how how are we
going to know maybe it could be anything
i could say like you're like really good
at walking what no a really good walk in
the movie who knew that you are such a
good walker everyone knows i'm a good
walker
you always know really good jewelry
stores
yeah hidden talents it's not so hidden
that's my accountant
so i think i won uh well we no we
chalked it up to a tie we're going to
get to know each other better on this
press tour
next time we do this there's a lot more
questions like this will be better
please go see the batman it's out on
march 4th march 4th and it's going to be
great
yeah yeah
i can pick up things to do something
ready yeah do it no but i can okay bye
[Music]
you